[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
ce soir nous parlerons de la culture
depuis le mois de mars le monde culturel
et au ralenti voire à l'arrêt avec
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
nous verrons si ce n'est pas un univers
oublier en cette période de crise de
crise sanitaire selon une étude du
ministère de la culture rendue publique
en juillet la chute du chiffre
d'affaires global est estimé à 22 3
milliards d'euros le secteur le plus
touché celui du spectacle vivant avec 72
% de baisse
loin devant le patrimoine les arts
visuels et larchitecture alors trois
invités sont ce soir en plateau avec
nous physiquement que john jay mad
cofondateur de la compagnie de danse
black blanc beur pierre henry gates
créateur et metteur en scène de la
troupe en chantier compagnie de théâtre
fondée en 2014 est composée de comédiens
amateurs et en visio josé cachin le
maire adjoint en charge de la culture à
montigny le bretonneux bonjour à tous
les trois alors j'aimerais commencer
avec vous josé cachant c'est peut-être
l'aspect le plus visible de la situation
les saisons culturelles complètement
chamboulée à montigny le bretonneux la
billetterie pour la saison de l'as
ouvert qu'en septembre
vous attendiez de voir où en était la
situation sanitaire à vous nous vous
lancer alors bien évidemment bien
évidemment lancer la saison tel qu on le
fait habituellement c'est à dire au mois
de juin paraissait invraisemblable au vu
du contexte que l'on était en train de
traverser
et puis la rentrée de septembre
n'étaient guère plus rassurantes donc
nous avions nous avons pris plusieurs
initiatives par rapport à ça
habituellement lorsqu'on ouvre la
billetterie des spectacles on ouvre une
billetterie sur une saison complète
c'est-à-dire de de septembre à juin
cette fois ci nous avons pris la
décision de nous la billetterie que
jusqu'au mois de décembre
car l'impact l'impact est fort impact
financier fort et avec ce questionnement
aussi de savoir si le public allait
répondre présent à cette ouverture de
billetterie voilà voilà en quelque sorte
la façon dont les choses se sont passées
maintenant bon je pourrais m'étendre un
petit peu sur le sujet je vais aussi
laisser la parole la parole ou deux
invités que vous avez sur le plateau
parce que je pourrais en parler mais
justement vous dites que la crainte que
les gens ne retournent pas dans les
salles de spectacle on le voit avec le
cinéma en septembre la fréquentation
était de -1 51% par rapport à 2019 et
cette fréquentation l'envié de retourner
dans les salles c'est l'objet de notre
question aux téléspectateurs la question
maintenez vous vos sorties culturelles
cinémas théâtres musées concert malgré
la crise sanitaire et les mesures mises
en place par le gouvernement et nos
téléspectateurs ont répondu à 53%
non j'en jemal vous vous êtes plutôt du
côté de la scène c'est un résultat que
vous comprenez que vous craignez ben oui
qui est moins de fréquentation on le
craint forcément mais au-delà de cette
conjoncture ce qui est en train de se
détruire c'est un type de rapports entre
les gens ou l'art je salue sa part nous
son rôle et ça c'est encore plus
inquiétant parce que ça nous met en
perspective d'une forme de société ou
comment dire elle ce rôle que l'art et
j'ai pas dit la culture pour le coup
parce que je distingue bien l'art dans
ce qu'on peut ensuite concevoir comme la
culture que ce rôle vis aujourd'hui faut
réfléchir à des alternatives qui nous
permettent de cultiver notre désir de
faire société de fer groupe
c'est vraiment le fond de la question
alors évidemment sur la conjoncture on
peut toujours répondre qu' on aimerait
bien que ça soit rouvert
en consultant un petit peu le milieu
professionnel enfin celui dans lequel on
est immergé depuis tant d'années on se
rend compte que sa force aussi l'avant
l'invention l'imagination qui a des
lieux qui ont réussi à la plupart
évidemment à la faveur de l'été sont
sortis ont re découvert le parc comme
disait aristote complète pour le faisait
dire à aristote
voilà donc ça c'est un côté assez
positif maintenant ce qu'il faut ce qui
apparaît je termine là dessus c'est que
il ya une catastrophe en route est
annoncé au moins à court terme pour les
gens dont c'est le métier et sans doute
mais je ne dirais pas votre place
quelqu un impact vous avez forcément
parce que on est aussi amateur
cette distraction pour nouveaux-nés
particularité si vous n'êtes pas
professionnel pour le moment et amateurs
mais ce manque de public vous le
ressentez vous n'avez repris la scène
qu'au mois de septembre
oui absolument ces heures déjà
l'incertitude elle et à tous les niveaux
en fait c'est à dire que nous dans
l'organisation des spectacles
mais comme la plupart du temps on est en
partenariat avec les municipalités mal
elle ressemble pas il ressentit
incertitude également vis-à-vis du
public et vis-à-vis également des
directives gouvernementales dans le sens
où ce qu'on leur dit n'est pas clair et
je prends pour exemple justement la
première représentation qu'on a fait de
cette saison c'était le 26 septembre
dernier à voisins le bretonneux et tout
début septembre la municipalité nous
annonce que
il va falloir respecter une distance de
20 comment dire un espace de 4 mètres
carrés par spectateur dans une salle de
100 places ça nous avait réduit la jauge
à 22 places on a beaucoup hésité à
maintenir certaines troupes ont pas
nulles et leur représentation et nous
une semaine avant nous a livré
finalement là je remonte à 52 3 places
on a maintenu on a bien fait du coup
mais malgré ça m'a irin lausanne trois
places la dernière fois on avait joué là
bas on était complet bah là on a fait 45
place le sang vous êtes coûtant tous les
trois c'est le flou qui marque le plus
c'est l'incertitude sûr bien sûr qui est
partagé par d'autres acteurs nous sommes
allés à la rencontre d'un directeur de
salle et d'un maire pour qu'il nous
explique leur situation
l'incertitude continue dans un monde où
l'anticipation est le maître mot c'est
l'inconnu qui reste pour le monde
culturel au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'activité a
repris le 18 mai dernier avec la
réouverture de la billetterie consignes
à respecter et public plus clairsemé
on va être à 60 65 % de la jauge on a
aussi des abonnements qui permettent
cette souplesse puisque en plus des
abonnements traditionnels qui oblige
entre guillemets à prendre quatre ou
huit spectacles dès le départ là on a
également des cartes saison qui
permettent de prendre des spectacles 1
donc on essaie d'être le plus souple
possible du côté de coignières on a fait
le choix d'une saison progressive
la municipalité propose depuis la
rentrée des représentations courte d'une
heure avec des jauges de 150 personnes
on est sur un redémarrage de la saison
culturelle à coignières mais un
redémarrage en quelque sorte prudent et
au ralenti c'est pour tester si nous
avons un public qui se déplacent parce
que ça non plus ce n'est pas forcément
garantie même si on sent quand même
qu'ils aient une envie des gens quand
même d'aller de retrouver les salles de
spectacle
en quelque sorte et de vivre tout
simplement les grands spectacles
professionnels devraient reprendre la
route du théâtre alphonse daudet au mois
de janvier 2021 alors il ya d'autres
communes qui ont choisi de différer la
reprise c'est le cas d'el en cours dont
la saison est présenté ce soir même au
prisme les premiers spectacles n'auront
lieu qu'en janvier josé callejón chez
vous les spectateurs ont repris le
chemin de la salle jacques brel et de la
ferme du mas né le 3 octobre dernier
vous le disiez la billetterie est
ouverte plus tard pas avant janvier et
mai vous avez programmé jusqu'au bout
pardon jusqu'au mois de mai prochain
est-ce que ça a été plus dur à faire ou
pas de ce programme est de cette manière
je vais si vous vous souciez vous
permettez je vais élargir un petit peu
votre question là j'ose moi je souhaite
rebondir sur ce que sur ce qui a été dit
sur le plateau on est dans l'incertitude
aujourd'hui mais on est dans
l'incompréhension la plus totale
il va falloir qu'on m'explique pourquoi
je vais vous donner l'exemple des
transports en commun pourquoi
aujourd'hui dans les transports en
commun on n'a pas de siège à respecter
entre chaque voyageur et pourquoi
continue à nous contraindre dans les
salles de spectacle alors même que le
protocole sanitaire en vigueur été mise
en place
et ce ne sont des lieux on ne peut plus
sécurisé qui nous contraignent
finalement à revoir
jose une jauge à la baisse moi je
rejoins ce que disent et lionel bah
c'est à c'est à dire qu'on est sur un
taux de remplissage à hauteur de 60% et
qui fait qu' on a une perte financière
et n'en soyons clair moi la saison elle
me coûte cent mille euros de plus elle
me coûte cent mille euros de plus par ce
que parce que j'ai des recettes en moins
la deuxième chose que je vais évoquer
c'est que on a un état qui aujourd'hui
assimile les collectivités locales à
l'état et donc autant il ya des
dispositions financières qui ont été
mises en place
pour les producteurs de spectacles etc
et ça c'est tout à fait recevable
autant on ne se préoccupe pas de
l'impact budgétaire que ça peut avoir
sur les collectivités locales
nous à notre niveau on vient de faire un
courrier à l'attention de la ministre de
la culture où on demande à être soutenus
financièrement parce que nous sommes
aussi nous sommes nous produisons
également des spectacles
nous avons cette possibilité de le faire
dès financièrement je ne comprends pas
qu'on soit pas aidé par rapport à ça
annoncé par le gouvernement en septembre
dernier
il ya aussi un flou sur ce que les
collectivités vont pouvoir dont vous les
collectivités vont pouvoir bénéficier
amelia il ya plus qu'un flou n'a plus
qu'un flou c'est même pas une
incertitude c'est pire que ça je veux
dire et puis aujourd'hui il faut pas
oublier que vous avez des gros
producteurs de spectacles qui e mail
leur saison tambour battant et et non
pas tellement de problèmes parce qu'ils
ont les moyens de rebondir mais là on
est en train de signer l'arrêt de mort
des petites productions
parce que eux
bah n'arrive pas à égaler les spectacles
à une telle frilosité de la part des
collectivités locales et ça peut se
comprendre qui font que les choses ne
peuvent pas se mettre en place
maintenant pour répondre plus
précisément à votre question concernant
la saison culturelle de sa vie une
saison culturelle ça se prépare un an
voire un an et demi à l'avance donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si on
veut être en mesure de pouvoir faire une
programmation de qualité
il nous faut mettre d'abord des options
puis des engagements contractualiser
auprès des productions revenir en
arrière
annoncé aux productions aujourd'hui que
les spectacles ne peuvent pas se
produire ça sous-entend aussi de devoir
rembourser des contrats de cession mais
ça veut dire aussi se mettre en quelque
sorte certaines productions à dos et
c'est toute la difficulté programmé dans
l'avenir la production la mise en place
de spectacles c'est un réseau il faut il
faut entendre les uns et des autres donc
nous en ce qui nous concerne sur la
saison à venir comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure on a une programmation
qui de toute façon est annuelle et elle
est arrêtée comme ça l'est resté
jusqu'au mois de juin
on voulait s'assurer que le premier
trimestre que le public puisse répondre
présent au premier trimestre et là on a
une vraie participation du public
la même que d'habitude la même que
d'habitude c'est vous dire un de
spectacles a affiché complet en deux
minutes
au moment de l'ouverture de la
billetterie donc le public est bien
présent maintenant nous on se doit de
notre côté de de faire les choses avec
une extrême vigilance de calcul et
financièrement l'impact que cela peut
avoir
voilà mais il n'empêche qu'il faut que
tout ça redémarre à un moment donné il
faut que tous les acteurs puissent jouer
pleinement leur rôle et notre sol soit
aujourd'hui il que d'autres soient
politiques c'est de faire en sorte que
la culture et la place prépondérante
qu'elle doit avoir parce que je crois
que c'est aussi le aller le domaine
peut-être le plus le plus important
qui doit être mis en avant aujourd'hui
par rapport au contexte qu'on traverse
il faut que les gens puissent à nouveau
s'évader gens que j'ai mal je voudrais
sur ce qu'elle dit josé kasha les
subventions la frilosité de certaines
salles à ce que les baies 3 ont du mal à
se produire aujourd'hui les deux choses
les baies 3 nous on est en train de
terminer cette histoire et christine
donc on peut plus être vraiment
opposable mais on a quand même une
expérience qui nous permet d'observer
chaud et puis on se pose des questions
pour renault une heure qu'ils vont
devenir la compagnie emprunte alors
quand les entreprises sont de petite
taille et bien c'est paradoxal parce
qu'elles subissent moins quand il ya des
dommages il fallait pas être le cirque
du soleil fallait pas être des
mégastructures parce que là c'est clair
ça descend en flammes mais ce que je
voulais dire et pour aller dans le sens
de ce que je viens de dire monsieur
l'adjoint au maire de montigny mais oui
c'est un ensemble n'y a pas un endroit
où il faut remettre un endroit faux pas
en mettre six donc c'est qu'on n'a pas
perçu comment tout ça est une daube
alité subtil enchevêtrées prenons un
exemple extrêmement simple aujourd'hui
les fonds que la mise de la culture
propose sont à moitié pour moitié
conditionné à la réussite de la première
partie du projet mais si tous les moyens
sont mis sur un secteur
il est certain que ce secteur aura un
petit peu les jours aux six mois de plus
que les autres où est ce que je dis mais
que tout ça c'est parti pour la nécrose
quand même donc j'insiste violemment là
dessus et effectivement pour moi c'est
presque un jeu de bonneteau
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment où
d'abord il faut prendre au sérieux les
collectivités territoriales là il ya un
moment où l'état français en particulier
doit se soigner un petit peu de son
jacobinisme
c'est exactement ça c'est une vraie
question est donc arrêter de prendre les
gens des provinces des villes
extérieures pour des imbéciles ou des
gens qui ont besoin de recevoir la leçon
de l'état je pense que j'espère que ça
va vraiment revenir et que et qu'on va
mettre au travail
on va se mettre au travail sur cette
question et la deuxième chose
c'est comment dirais-je bien sûr il faut
re questionner les formes mais il faut
rappeler même si ça fait pas cette fois
l'industrie automobile comme disait
notre ministre de la culture mais
visiblement deux fois ce qui n'est quand
même pas rien que hormis l'aspect
économique de la culture
mais nos sociétés pour vivre en sang
sont fondées là dessus alors j'ajoute un
autre coin un autre point c'est le
patrimoine
il faut faire attention à ce que le
patrimoine ne viennent pas un espace de
conservation élitiste sédimenter mais
faut pas dire non plus qu'il faut pas
travailler sur la mémoire et sur le
patrimoine parce que des patrimoines y
en a toutes sortes
il y en a des récents il y en a qui sont
à projeter dans la capacité qu'ont à
d'inventer au futur est ce que justement
cette situation aujourd'hui ne pousse
pas les troupes a changé de format on le
voit à coignières bien au reggae
ils font des formats courts est ce que
vous seriez amené vous à à retravailler
en tant qu'auteur comme étant rancennes
est ce que vous seriez prêt à modifier
des oeuvres pour aujourd'hui monter sur
scène si vous n'êtes pas entendu plein
de mystères de la création
moi je trouverais freeix extrêmement
déprimant d'en arriver là sauf que c'est
c'est admirable qu'ils arrivent à le
faire mais moins pour ma part c'est pas
possible clairement là par exemple en ce
moment on est en train de monter deux
projets différents
une pièce qui dure 1h40 une autre qui
endurent 1h25 je n'ai pas commencé à
m'amuser à sabrer dans mes pièces pour
voilà les dénaturer au final pour enfin
pouvoir les jouer ça m'intéresse pas on
sait ce qu'on veut présenter au public
c'est quelque chose de cohérent et puis
le public a besoin de ça s'ils se
déplacent et pas pour voir un format
court juste pour dire je suis allé au
théâtre ce soir
en fait c'est pas ça je pense que ça
n'intéresse personne si effectivement il
ya de nouvelles créations qui sont
faites par des compagnies et voilà
qu'elle se restreignent en créant à ce
format d'une heure évidemment pourquoi
pas et je les encourage à le faire mais
mais nous on souhaite pas ça et je
rebondis sur ce que disait monsieur
monsieur l'adjoint au maire
effectivement il ya un manque de
cohérence flagrant puisque comme le
thème de la discussion c'est savoir si
la culture est un peu un monde oublié
on a ce sentiment là que ce soit dans le
milieu je pense professionnelle ou dans
le secteur associatif
je pense pas que c'est forcément un
manque de 2,2 de cohésion de
considération mais voilà il ya des
mesures qui sont pris des décisions qui
sont prises et ce dont j'ai l'impression
c'est que ce qui manque c'est la
concertation avec les gens concernés
parce que quand on quand on entend ces
mesures on s'est dit mais qui les attend
ce qu'ils pensent que c'est envisageable
que c'est applicable et que ça va
permettre la survie de la culture on est
en train là si ça continue comme ça de
de tuer ces secteurs ce qu'on parle là
des salles municipales c'est une chose
c'est un débat il ya aussi quand on
regarde par exemple dans paris il ya des
grands théâtres qui vont ouvrir et qui
accueillir du public qui vont pouvoir
survivre quand ils ont 500 plasma
survivre sur 250 300 places mais les
petits caveau les petites salles qui ont
75 50 places comment ils vont faire pour
survivre c'est terminé ces lauréats qui
ont déjà du mal à remonter tous les
trois vous regardez avec précision les
annonces qui arrivent chaque jour qui
change
j'imagine que hugues à ce flou là aussi
de voir les gens début et puis on voit
quand même je vais juste monsieur vous
allez commencer on passe les pouvois
sera la parole monsieur cache un nom vu
l'ampleur du de de la méprise on se rend
bien compte dans quelle phase on est
c'est à dire que même si un pan de ce
paradigme furieux s'éclaircit on sait
que tout le reste ne fonctionnera pas
donc j'y vois la peine de rester toutes
les 5 minutes avec un chronomètre pour
se dire attends je vais avoir une mesure
à peu je fonce sanaa au ça ne sert
absolument et josé cachant j'imagine
aussi que vous à chaque fois à chaque
nouvelle mesure vous vous dites comment
l'adapter à votre situation
j'en souris gens sourit aujourd'hui je
rejoins ce que disait monsieur
j'en arrive à un point si vous voulez où
je regarde plus ce qui se passe parce
que je suis tellement dépité par rapport
à tout ça que un moment donné voilà il
faut il faut en prendre son parti il
faut il faut il faut aussi assumer des
choses il faut faire le choix de de
continuer à promouvoir toutes les
actions culturelles quelle qu'elle soit
avec toutes les difficultés que cela
comporte parce que là on évoque on
évoque des saisons culturelles etc
vous savez moi j'ai 89 associations
culturelles à gérer sur la ville et dont
dont un certain nombre d'associations de
théâtre amateur on a en face de nous des
personnes dans le cadre associatif pour
lesquels moi je voue une admiration sans
faille pour pour leur dévouement pour
apporte tout ce qu'elle fait parce que
finalement on sait très bien que tissu
associatif c'est ce qui aujourd'hui
feder et assure le lien social entre
entre tous les les individus et on est
en train de sabrer cette chose-là quoi
on est en train de tuer on est en train
de tuer le tout ce qui touche à la
solidarité donc qu'est ce que je vous
dise moi je suis qu'est ce que
j'aimerais avoir en face de moi
la ministre de la culture ou le
président de la république qu'est ce que
j'aimerais maintenant est ce qu'ils sont
en mesure de pouvoir entendre j'ai plein
de sentiments pour le moment que ce soit
le cas à quoi rire monsieur le maire ça
soit un fantasme entendre dans ces mêmes
vous savez combien et comment ils sont
remarquera aussi qu'on parle
beaucoup des artistes de ceux qui sont
sur scène mais le métier du spectacle
il ya aussi beaucoup de personnes dans
l'ombre
josé cachin j'imagine qu'à montini tout
ce qui est technicien lumière
techniciens sont c'est compliqué aussi
pour eux ils ont peut-être l'impression
de d'être à l'arrêt mais on est on
piétine tous on piétine tous et g22 sa
leçon que sont la ferme du mas n'est que
sont la salle jacques brel
vous imaginez bien que bon d'abord que
pendant toute la période de confinement
qu'on a traversées on avait un personnel
qui était à l'arrêt et qui est
aujourd'hui est toujours en phase de
questionnement pour savoir s'ils vont
être en mesure de pouvoir travailler ou
pas donc on a remis les choses en ordre
depuis le mois de septembre parce que
malgré tout on a réouvert les
équipements et et on lance une saison
même effectif réduit mais en tout cas on
lance une saison donc ils sont repartis
au travail mais quand on voit les
changements de situation qui arrive
quasi quotidiennement sur les protocoles
nouveau etc etc
évidemment tout le monde s'interroge
tout le monde s'interroge on est en
phase de questionnement tout le temps et
l'impact il est est ce que c'est ça
aussi que l'état ne mesure pas je veux
dire c'est les effets collatéraux que ça
peut avoir c'est ça le plus grave je
veux dire c'est toutes ces personnes qui
sont dans l'incertitude complète quant
au maintien de leur emploi
pire c'est ça des effets ça a été très
bien dit tout à l'heure on a des choses
qui se nécrosent un peu partout les
petites salles parisiennes leur devenir
est plus que compromis j'avais encore
hier au téléphone le producteur don à un
petit producteur là qui aimait qui me
dit mais je ne m'en sors pas quoi
financièrement je m'en sors pas je sais
pas aujourd'hui comment comment les
choses vont se passer quoi moi je
rencontrais par jean je fréquente depuis
des années il ya en gros deux catégories
après il y en ad'autres m'enfin c'est
pour saisir ce qui était intermittents
au moment locaux vides est arrivé bon il
ya une respiration
ça laissera voilà ça je parle en droit
d'internet sensuellement et des
techniciens
par contre j'ai eu hier mais c'est pas
hasard et j'en aurai demain des gens des
amis au téléphone
enfin des gens avec qui on a fait la
route depuis des années qu'ils n'ont pas
eu le temps de renouveler compas eu les
moyens de renouveler leur intermittence
qu'attendait 80 heures de tel ou tel
telle ou telle et telle radio mais comme
c'est parti en vrille dans tous les sens
tout est parti e 10 existe nulle part
alors ça je suis ravi d'être à la télé
pour le dire parce que voilà des gens
qui sont eux qui sont à la rue quoi là
on n'est même plus dans les petites
inquiétudes en allant se coucher là on
est face à des gens qui ne peuvent plus
manger 1 et du côté des techniciens
voyons peu dire enfin je suis en contact
bon et fitch et a par 65 ans ça fait un
moment sur quarante ans que je suis dans
ce métier et j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui
arrive à la cinquantaine etc ils sont
restés trois mois sans bosser y
reviennent et il doit reporter des
machines régler des machins vous
imaginez sur le plan de la santé voyez
c'est simplement une image pour toucher
du bout du doigt la manière avec
laquelle tout se tient et jamal vont
terminer que vous plaire en vigueur
juste avant cette émission vous confiez
qu'en plus ça stoppe certains projets
vous aviez l'envié de passer
professionnel c'est ça c'était c'était
l'idée avec un des projets qu'on
développe cette année avec avec trois de
mes comédiens
donc c'est une pièce s'appelle 1494
jours donc on est
ça fait ça fait un an et demi deux ans
qu'on travaille dessus on a fait une
première le 29 février à versailles et
juste avant de confinement voilà dernier
spectacle c'est mon dernier spectacle
pour la petite anecdote le 6 mars
j'ai attrapé le coc vide le 4 mars
qu'une cloche était sur scène je mettais
dopée uniquement fernand dernier
spectacle avant que le confinement et
voilà donc là on a repris ses spectacles
qu'on a joué à voisin le 26 septembre
on le joue là ce vendredi au festival de
tsc la situation vous dis ben non on a
même l'année prochaine on fait pas ce
projet passé professionnel en ciel pas
sûr parce que justement on parlait des
petites salles tout à l'heure on avait
prévu de jouer dans un petit théâtre
parisien de ta pixels sur six dates
entre janvier et février
là on sait pas encore c'est à dire que
est-ce qu'on va repousser ce qu'on va
annuler est-ce qu'on va repousser au
moins parce que le fait de se lancer
dans le monde professionnel pour ça
allait jouer à paris c'est bien mais il
faut faire venir les gens que ça peut
intéresser donc les producteurs les
directeurs de théâtre et est ce qu'ils
vont vraiment se déplacer dans la
conjoncture actuelle j'en suis pas
certain donc c'est une discussion qu'on
va voir on va jouer vendredi on devait
jouer samedi c'était annulé à versailles
c'est une salle privée qui a pris la
décision d'interdire toutes les
manifestations accueillant du public
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
on va je respecte la décision évidemment
un
on reviendra là bas un peu plus tard on
l'espère en tout cas mais c'est vrai que
c'est délicat de se projeter pour le
moment on attend on essaye de faire
preuve de patience mais il faut qu'ils
aient du répondant du côté du
gouvernement et que les mesures soient
plus claires et j'ai envie de dire plus
intelligente et intelligible parce que
pour le moment
clairement on s'y retrouve pas ça
correspond pas voilà plus on consomme 10
samedi une maladie avec tous les
secteurs c'est sur ces mots là qu'on va
s'arrêter moins on aura bien compris
c'est le flou c'est la patience
finalement il va falloir patienter et
c'est aussi la fin de ce site une
société qui s'intéressait à la culture
en période de kovy 19 josé kaeslin la
saison il y monte à une continue donc ce
vendredi 9 octobre c'est un concert
complet celui ci celui de michael
gregorio genre 'je emad les baies 3
juniors seront alors le succès des
spectacles ont été repoussés voilà les
seront sur la scène de l'âne de la
merise le 23 janvier
et bien avant vegas vous l'avez dit le 9
octobre vous participez au festival de
bougival avec 1494 jour merci à tous les
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour échanger sur ce sujet dont on
pourrait parler bien sûr pendant des
heures le 7-8 société revient la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau mouvement des
changes
[Musique]